uh i mean i'm a confident person i've
always been this way and my teammates
did a great job of finding me down the
stretch um and obviously for with me i
was just
you know i put in a lot of work at the
end of the day you know i'm ready for
those moments i believe every shot that
i take
has a chance to go in and you have to
have that mentality if you want to be
successful at this level with other
elite athletes so
um
yeah i was ready i was ready for it and
plus there was you know some hecklers
during the game talking to me so i had
to
it was their fault really it was their
fault
well we saw you turn
from our advantage one we couldn't hear
yeah
yeah that was for them yeah they had a
sign they had to sign up and said uh
uh
lebron won uh kuzma his ring
and uh you know i i said uh you know
without lebron
cleveland would be [ __ ] so
um
you know that they they chose violence
and i just kept going so
thank you guys appreciate it
just to be clear would you say they
didn't touch your not violence but you
know they're just talking too much